[Musique]
je viens pour déjà récupéré mon pare que
je commande sur l'homme un site et qui
me permet de prendre de bons copains de
sylvain qui est un parti annales que
j'aime beaucoup
voilà donc déjà il ya mon pain puisqu'au
moment de régulièrement puis j'ai
découvert le marché de des usines
maintenant je le fréquente tous les
vendredis parce que je trouve des
produits souvent pour des produits
locaux des très bons de très bonne
qualité
alors le confinement il déconfinement
bas ça n'a pas changé la météo ni le
rythme des saisons donc le
le travail est resté identique avec
c'était la période de des plantations de
tous les légumes de printemps et d'été
il ya un petit peu de récoltes mais
c'est le ça correspondait pour moi qui
suis que en 2e année d'installation ça
correspondait à la période creuse ou
avec peu de légumes
donc j'ai maintes j'ai pu maintenir deux
points de vente avec la cage est
d'obliger et puis
la ferme du champ du bois à marseille et
puis après le marché petit à petit a
repris au déconfinement et le public a
été là il a répondu présentes qui était
vraiment une bonne surprise poids est un
producteur d'huîtres non triploïdes
naturel ça m'a tout de suite intéressé
j'ai proposé ma candidature entre
guillemets et ça a tout de suite fixe
acceptée et tout le monde était très
content mais je vienne alors c'est le
but qui sont donc nées en mer on capte
notre propre dessin où on est sur la
sorte donc sur four a donc c'est une
zone où il ya beaucoup de captage
on pose nos propres coupelles et cetera
on récupère nos n'est certain qu'on
élève pendant trois à quatre ans voilà
on fait tout le stade de produits on
n'achète pas on fait notre auto
production pendant le confinement il ya
eu
il ya eu vraiment grand engouement et
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont appelé pour
essayer de s'approvisionner localement
et après le déconfinement je pense que
le rythme du
[Musique]
du travail a repris à nouveau la
fréquentation a rebaissé dans un niveau
qui était un peu près celui du précédent
mais j'espère comme il ya des mécanismes
d habitude qui commence à se reprendre
avec ça je crois qu'il faut promouvoir
un maximum les marchés locaux les
produits de proximité
voilà donc j'aime bien venir ici c'est
une ambiance particulière
c'est sympa
[Musique]